got on got alpha was out of my way
what is it signify again what's it mean
if the phase shift right so now I can
say therefore I'd have to run five so X
minus cos x equals two I don't know how
to deal with that except we got ears
like I'm going to replace it with a new
version of the C function just dress up
one evening so I'm going to right now
the square root of 26 sine X minus
eleven point three
that's our sine X minus alpha agree
that's equal to two that's the equation
of solving so I've turned to trig
functions into one and now I can solve
this just like all the other one that's
all before I guess I'll divide through
and just like before I'm going to say Oh
sign us on a belief with that I'll just
love the exact value again so I'm just
going to go shift sign and I should get
two solutions advocates right go ahead
go to your calculator go to shift sign
to on Ridgeway six if you hear a nice
small angle what is it twenty companies
2001 we're doing were wondering but we
know if you've got this a book you've
got a second solution do you remember
when we solve this with T results we've
got a second solution how do I find what
the second solution is
you can either do it this way or you can
do it this way right we're saying 23.1
is a solution something with that so
with the other solution come in
we're moving one solution with the of on
it's over in this quadrant right s the
sign because sine is positive to that so
not there so 23.1 ki art means 180 minus
back can you give me a number
point one point note okay and you can
confirm that over here right so in a bit
off that's it so it's twenty point one
degrees team of solution is for develop
90 that's point five to twenty three
point one's about math so you can see if
not the solution then that's also a
solution safety of 180 minus this number
okay cool is there I don't know next
year I have X take away eleven point
three so what should I do to a science
I'll just add 11.3 by eleven point three
the other side I should get a number
that I recognize from thirty four point
four that's what we got my two zones
ultimate do you remember I showed you
yes or what the other on you at eleven
point three and you get a hundred and
sixty eight point four that right
everyone but you question what you
through subtracting that a degree from
again I hope that's what we get using
our brain anyway so you can see
confirmation of the fact that just like
we got before I got this pair of
solution okay now let me make two notes
these are both an advantage and a
disadvantage when compared to tea
results
the advantage is at this point by
opening angle plan done finished I don't
have to do anything else if I saw this
mighty result there's one last thing I
need to do what's that I you test right
I've got to go back I've got to check it
out like a solution no great those that
did okay so this is the advantage that
all to the vehicle has the elderly angle
also has a disadvantage look on the
board do you see I've got a domain up
here 0 to 360 which is long okay however
by using auxiliary angle we've shifted
things see that so do you remember when
I told you say okay let's do a simple 1
2 x equals 1/2
I should solve this from north to 360
how many solutions do you expect your
success for because usually this - but
I've made it wave on the ground twice as
awesome now a nice clear way to see that
if this is a longer function in X it's a
function in 2 X so therefore your domain
really acts more like this then like
this does that make sense I know they're
equal but now you're like oh of course
I'll get more solution because it goes
off the log on there the phase
introduces the issue right see you right
I'm no longer really solving from north
to 360 I'm actually solving takeaway
11.3 from negative eleven point three
three to three hundred and forty eight
point seven two grapes so when you go
and find your solutions right many days
here you're not thinking about our day
between nine three sixty you actually
have a big are they between children
here now I chose this example specific
because actually I don't want to spit
you out too much this is fine
those are solutions okay but just
suppose I noted this changed during okay
I got there at the end of here I saw
this weird value star rich for my
calculator okay and then I got some
solution out here just suppose cuz it's
plausible just suppose I got like 350
degrees this one of the answers suppose
fourth quadrant was missing modules okay
that solution even though the solution
because it's outside this domain right
and you can see because if I am what
would happen if I add the eleven point
three to get to the next line the final
lines what happens to this when I add
eleven point three it will become three
hundred and sixty one point three which
is outside where original domain do you
see that
so these answers here depending on what
your exhilarating --gel that you find is
sometimes go outside the domain okay so
this is the cost this is a benefit there
forget about testing you got solutions
there solutions you have to worry about
that you've gone wrong but you have to
deal with this and this is a very tricky
not easy you can't avoid it you're
sometimes just get given this question
you can get to choose whether it is
ordinary angle to use off describe here
does that but um it's still look nice
like look at that my great hair just
look at them okay so watch out for
any questions
you may need to get those guarantees and
you can go to use that restriction on
the corrected fill example correct so
that's on the apples of 360 yes then it
was give me no you guys it's not between
negative eleven point three and three
hundred forty seven point whatever so
super y'all wanting of it yes it is
nothing is what you would have to do is
watch the disability so you know how I
said on 350 degrees that ends up being
it does when you add 11.3 right if this
one is a dark zone trig function century
like right there's another solution just
like this one 360 degrees early on if
350 is a solution then if you grow 360
degrees backwards what do you get you
get negative 10
now you want to think of negative ten
usually it was like sick of ten what
does that have to do with this obviously
not really negative ten it's maybe of
ten lost eleven point three what's
negative ten possible great it's a 1.3
which sneaks into the actual domain
do you see that so you wouldn't abandon
350 degrees you think that guy is no
good
like he's outside but he has a cousin
360 degrees per yard and that easy
solution you should still get to
that description falen okay so to think
about which restrictions you do this and
you think about which function you're
solving for from this line to this line
I'm solving this function so it's it's
not a functioning at it's a function in
X minus eleven point three so therefore
is this is why I should've written so
this is the domain that relates to this
could look as X minus another future
once I get to this line look there's no
X minus eleven point three so now you're
back in this plane does that make sense